good morning
i i like to make these first thing in
the morning
because so like most of us will wake up
we'll have a thought in our head
something's going well there and
there's not many good things about
getting old but one is you have
lots of memories we're all young ones so
i have lots of members
and i was asked a question
one of the great things about facebook
is it connects you with people
across the world and i've had
conversations
from australia quite a few
from america and
i did say that i wanted to answer
questions if people
had any thoughts of what my
ideas or my thoughts are again they're
my
ideas they're no one else's could be
completely wrong it's only you know
we see things and hear things with our
eyes and ears and our mind
contemplates them when you're young
you're so keen and so excited about
whatever it is you're doing
that you can be blinded by
what is truly there and what is
what is really to be seen
now one of the questions i was asked was
what do i think about cytosenses
uh how he
did he carry on and explaining him about
the philosophy of our scentsy
or was he just teaching his technical
this is a really easy one to answer but
could be quite a long story to tell
i might have to do it in more than one
session
saito sensei made it quite clear
that he wanted the world to know oh
sense is technical
and he wanted to show i
sense his technical format on how it
should be built up
and starting from kion what means solid
basic
and so and a lot of the more flowing
teachers
doesn't matter whether they're japanese
or european
western-minded ones they tend to twist
what is basic
and of course the students pick up this
and they say oh this is basic
and they show you a technique on the
move that's not basic
when you go into a shop to buy something
it's usually
sitting there on the shelf or in a
position
it's in a static position and you go up
to it
and you look at it the same as i'm
looking
into this camera the camera's static
i tend to be moving a little bit
so the camera's in a basic position
and that's solid basic it's grounded by
the tripod
and in aikido oh sensei
said that his hammy his stance was
the tripod the strong posture
so until you can learn this
why would you want to go forward we all
want to go forward we all want to be the
best in the world
well i didn't know until i started
going to seminars outside my own dojo
and after well a few years really
i decided i'm not going to be the best
in the world
perhaps i can be the best in europe i
thought
i wanted to see more of the world and
soto sensei traveled a lot
and i wanted to see him
and the more i saw and the more i saw
some of these higher
level teachers and students that he'd
been teaching for a lot longer than me
i realized i wasn't going to be the best
in europe anymore
i know if i can be the best in the uk
that's what i'm aiming for
i still remember thinking this uh this
stupid thoughts but
are they stupid something's got to keep
us going and make us
eager if i can be the best in the uk
they'll know i think that's good enough
the trouble is there was more people in
the uk started to follow the obama star
like you know
and as i've said i'm a slow learner
in previous films
well they're getting better than me
where they seem to be
their techniques seem to be better
i'll have to just go along in my own way
and as like as would have it i've always
had
my own dojos i've built them in my
garden
i've built one at my business practice
so i've always been fortunate i can just
step into my dojo
and one day i was kneeling in front of
oscenzi
and i said in my mind to him
teach me what i need to know
because i don't think i'm doing so good
on my own
the answer i got back was
try to be the best in your own dojo and
settle for that
so that's my advice to anybody who's
thinking of big things trying to be the
best you can
now going back to the question i was
asked
what's cytosensei
uh teaching o senses philosophy
no only the basics
he wanted to show people that you start
with solid tana hanka
okay grabs naga's wrist
nage is standing in a firm strong
position
in a static position bouquet approaches
the same as i talked about going to the
shop to buy something
we're in movement as we grab
nago's wrist we grab it 100
you'll notice that my hands are
extremely large
i've had jokes comments jcb
hands and many things
through my world's practice boxers hands
so i always was very very powerful
very strong so my grip to most people
wouldn't be able to move me
cytosensei said you must not
fight but you must do what you're asked
to do
so therefore i used to grab 100 my
partner
and i did notice that
being a male i would ease up on the
females because i knew they wouldn't
have the strength
to do the technique i believe inside of
sense's eyes that would have been wrong
and yet correct
because to embarrass somebody
or to just destroy them is not i sent
his way
it wasn't cited sent his way
but for a male you grew up as strong as
you can
have the intention that you you've done
what you've been asked of
but don't add thought don't add
aggression
don't add want just grip
the wrist as firmly as possible
that means that you've given 100
good intention to do what you've been
asked
cytosensitis also said if i asked for a
strike a shomonucci strike for mukey
i need a good strong 100 percent show
nuchi strike but you should be
professional enough
that if the person nage does not move
then don't hit them this is aggressive
we're we're trying to help naga improve
because in a few moments time
we will be nargo and you cannot keep
changing
your mind one minute i'm nage next
minute i'm okay
i'm okay i will take this fall and enjoy
the
high fall oh
i'm going to be clever this time and i'm
going to have a color quiche done on me
but i'm going to be faster than naggy
so i can surprise him and be out the
other side
just to show him or her that they can't
do code guys on me
this is this is uh
all the tricks that cytosensei and no
sensei didn't want you to do just do
what you're asked
just grip 100 just
strike 100 but never to hurt the person
be professional with a male
they should they never do not in my time
but they should actually ask you not so
strong
or 10 less and then they should try
taina hanker again
if you're gripping moonadore
then how can you ask them to grip less
you can't
so we start with china henka because
this
once you can overcome your ego
and ask for less strength
or less commitment i should say
then you can slowly build and when you
find that you can move every time at
that
75 or whatever it is and you can move
easily on all cameras and you can ask
all comers to ease back
then your ego will reduce you will
become a better person
and your aikido will grow
i will carry this conversation on in the
next segment
so i hope you enjoyed it please like it
or
unlike it and subscribe if you
would like to hear more with your
comments thank you